kahon is a product that will start will
be the front door that starts
communicating with the patient may
either when a patient schedules an
appointment or when a patient actually
comes in to the clinic or it could be on
a tele medicine uh uh consultation with
a physician kahon will first take the
the first step and and and have a
conversation with the patient it will be
in a chat b or some kind of digital uh
interface and Kon will ask the question
will really mimic the thought process of
taking a history for a patient taking a
history for a patient requires knowledge
and understanding of what the patient is
describing and what are the diseases
that need to be suspected and and the
follow-up
[Music]
questions mikal Kat welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
how are you thank you thank you for
having me I'm excited to have this 20
minute I'm really excited to dive into
your world in these 20 minutes you are
the co-founder and chief medical officer
at cahun Medical and you're looking at
evidence-based clinical reasoning tool
for Physicians so this whole integration
of AI and humans especially when it
comes to the medical scene I it's truly
fascinating in a world in which AI is
becoming such a prominent um you know
um theme within our work and and such an
integrator and and
creating a step function for our ability
to leverage these tools to to to do our
job better and at scale of course and so
I have a lot of questions about what
you're doing and it's going to be really
fun and interesting so tell me first a
little bit about yourself how did you
get into the whole medical scene I know
you were previously at several hospitals
within Israel I'd love to hear a little
bit about your background okay great so
we'll start there um so first it's it's
true I mean what we do what I'm doing in
what I'm ating my my life right now is
to building tools to to incorporate the
AI with with with a uh clinical thinking
human clinical thinking of of medical
practice and that's what I've been doing
for the past few few years but it all
started as as as you're trying to ask it
way back I mean I started medical school
after I was already a a um a programmer
a computer scientist and and and I
worked as a programmer for a few years
and and then only then I started med
school I started pretty late uh at the
age of
27 and and I think the whole medical
education for me was shifted was a
little bit different than your average
medical student because I was already
thinking how could we do this different
I was always thinking how can we do this
different how can we do this better how
can I educate myself with all the
uh uh knowledge you know when you study
medicine you started by with a
preclinical studies you you study the
basics you study the the the the anatomy
and the biophysics and the biochemistry
and then the pathology and so on and so
on it's it's a learning process that is
in layers and it's very primitive um you
get to memorize a lot of stuff and and
and and then build it layers by layers
until you get to the clinical
understanding of diseases and I then you
get into working in the words and and
and and when you get when you complete
medical studies and you go out into the
real world as and when I started you
know my residency really working in in
in in hospitals and and using utilizing
all the knowledge that I learned in the
real life again you're it's it's it's
amazing how it's only based on what this
tool has and there is no there there are
no tools that help me uh become uh more
uh uh better at at what I'm doing so so
it came from there uh it was a long
process understanding that this um that
there is a need to make us better
because we are limited as Physicians as
Ur and it's amazing how technology you
know is is everywhere in every field of
our lives but for some reason in in in
medical practice it wasn't yet uh it
hasn't yet uh um um was was never
incorporated into that well let me ask
you then you know you know to even
understand what are the possibilities
you know so you you understand the limit
you're limited by Nature how do you how
can you now understand what the
opportunities are so how do what do you
need to do in order to get from where
you where you're currently at and to
know how you can leverage technology to
make that step function so it's a great
question because it's not like uh you
can take technology and and and and um
make it do uh what we do as Physicians
it's it's it will never take over uh
everything all the aspects of being a
physician but there are some parts and
you have to understand that what kahun
uh what what what the professional uh
Physicians do is incorporate knowledge
and experience and the clinical skills
that you Pro that you build up and and
grow uh as uh during your career and
some
tools can help in these different
aspects it's not one tool that can help
everything so it's first of all being
open-minded to incorporating tools into
into the way we work so there are tools
that help us in the productivity and
there are tools that help us um in you
know in imaging and pathologies and so
on but there are also tools that need to
help us in clinical thinking and and
this is this is what excites me and this
is what excites me because this is the
core of of practicing medicine is the
decision making process it's it's what
we do in every in every moment of Our
Lives as uh when when we manage patients
it's everything that we have to do is
it's when we uh um question our patients
and when we examine them and when we are
thinking of which exams they need to be
to do for for further work up and we
will decide about the diagnosis and
where we decide about the treatment so
many decisions
and and in these in these core decisions
there are no tools right all right so
let's talk a little bit about cun
medical so what what is what are you
guys doing and and how are you
leveraging deep technology to to do
exactly this okay so when we started um
I was I was already um I was already
completed my residency in uh inov in uh
in saski medical center here in Tel Aviv
and we started meeting together me T and
aan there these are my two co-founders
here at kahun and I know them we are
friends from like way back because um
when I was working as a comp as a
programmer I was actually working in
company that they founded and later on
on and the company was sold to life
person um if you know this company maybe
and uh and and T Anda know each other
from even way before like from uh uh
high school but uh we also are friends
for a long time and we started to talk
about how we can leverage technology
into what Physicians do and what we
started at the beginning is we said that
the core the the the biggest gap for uh
for bring bringing tools into uh
Physicians uh workflow is BRD bridging a
gap between the knowledge the the
scientific knowledge that we as
Physicians base our decisions upon into
the uh uh into a structured format so
that you know we can use algorithms to
use this knowledge but it had to be um
very accurate that's you know medicine
is about accuracy it's an evidence-based
uh science it's not um it's not based on
Big Data it's not based it's when when
when I'm as a physician when I make a
decision I have to base it on evidence I
have to be updated with the latest
evidence and and so this was what we
started out doing is we started by
building a a
language that describes a structured
language that describes medical
knowledge between you know all the all
the all the understanding of diseases
their U pathology their uh
pathophysiology which means their uh
time course of diseases and their
manifestations and all the statistical
strength that comes from the literature
and the epidemiological data that comes
from the literature and all this is
captured into uh a Knowledge Graph this
is the core of kon's Technology it's the
knowledge representation of of of
medical literature and that was the
beginning and then we started just uh
using just uh building a very initial
proof of concept before we started kavun
before we started building the company
we built a proof of concept and when we
were like this took about a year uh that
we we worked on this before uh we we
started C and when we were convinced
that this is a way that could work on a
vast majority of of of uh disciplines in
in in medical areas then we started uh
building it from scratch in in in scale
interesting and so what what is the
actual product that you're providing to
Physicians and in their workflow how how
is sort of this human computer
interaction taking place so now now that
we have this you know and it keeps you
know it keep getting updated and it's
keeps uh growing all the time this
knowledge graph that holds the knowledge
and the algorithmic layer that mimics
the thought process of a physician and
this this this technology is and what we
do with it right now is we buildt tools
that are guiding the work of of
Physicians when patients are coming for
any medical uh services so kabon is a
product that will start will be the
front door that starts communicating
with the patient may either when a
patient schedules an appointment or when
a patient actually comes in to the
clinic or it could be a tele medicine uh
uh consultation with a physician cahun
will first take the the first step and
and and have a conversation with the
patient it will be in a chatboard or
some kind of digital uh interface and
kahon will ask the question will really
mimic the thought process of taking a
history for a patient taking a history
for a patient requires knowledge and
understanding of what the patient is
describing and what are the diseases
that need to be suspected and and the
follow-up questions and you know we're
working in a in a market that is very uh
that has different tools like symptom
Checkers and and stuff like that but um
the the the aim of of symptom checker is
more to to try and guess what the
patient has or to give the patient
information about their medical
condition the conversation that kavun
performs with the patient is not trying
to guess what the patient has it's
getting the raw information so that
later you can leverage it in in a
certain way I get that and and so tell
me a little bit about you know what what
you've learned about having meaningful
interactions with patients so what what
do you need to keep in mind as you're
building an AI platform that is going to
be speaking to patients because
essentially what we're talking about is
we have you know natural language
processing is a huge field chat Bots are
are you know hugely emerging we've seen
you know the likes of CH GPT Etc over
the over recent years what are what did
you what is sort of the fine-tuning that
you need to do for the medical space in
order for this to be you know a good
product this is I'm very glad you
brought this up because this is um I
mean what kahun does when kahun
communicates with a patient it's not
about the ability to communicate the the
the language it's
about performing the clinical reasoning
that is needed to ask the questions that
are that are most important that are
most significant in the patient
presentation so it's not just about you
know a patient coming in and describing
what they're complaining about and
having a a a like you know
conversational AI that understands what
the patient is saying it's about being
able to ask the patient questions that
are relevant to what they're describing
and as the data is accumulated during
the conversation again the different dis
es should be suspected and different
questions need to come up so it's about
it's like it's it's it's the engine that
drives the questions not just
understanding what the patient is saying
but the engine that drives what we need
to seek from the patient that's what
kahon is is about it's not so much about
the conversation on AI it's just one
part of it it's more about the clinical
reasoning the methodologic academic uh
reasoning that is that is that is the
the core of what kavun does and that's
it's it's almost like complementary on
top of conversation and I and natural
language processing is is um you know
it's they're they complement each other
uh in a way and together we can really
have an high level I can say even a gold
standard history taken from a patient
very and and this is just the first part
um I mean collecting data from a patient
in a conversation is just one part of
data collection that needs to be done
it's the subjective part it's asking the
patient what they're feeling and what
they're ex experiencing and what risk
factors they have and so on it's just
it's just one part of it and
then H there's the objective data
collection looking at the from The
Physician point of view it's searching
for which findings I need to look at on
a physical examination again the same
engine is used the same engine of kahon
that drives what I need to look for
maybe I need to look for an enlarged
liver in this patient maybe I need to
check if they have peritoneal signs in
their abdomen and so on and then and and
this goes on and goes on um this data
collection process and kahun continues
the whole path all the way to the
diagnosis and later on the treatment
This Not That this initial data
collection in the chat bot is just the
beginning of the journey yeah no that
makes sense and so what what is your
role as as chief medical officer in in a
company like this and what what does a
chief medical officer even do and then
the third question is why is it the
coolest job that anybody can
have okay that's a good question and it
is the coolest job ever um so I
think okay um what do I do as a chief
medical auor is you know I it's it's
more um you know building a company uh
that is trying to really uh bring or
change something so fundamental in the
process of how uh Physicians work and
what Physicians use uh to to to improve
their clinical decision- making is about
uh understanding the needs of the of the
of the of the providers understanding
medicine and how complex it is and what
and how we can capture all this
complexity and in in in uh in the
algorithms
and working together with different
teams so there's the development team
which is fantastic and there's the the
medical team at kahon and which are
amazing also and and it's about you know
communicating between the needs and the
complexity of the medicine and the the
way that we try to answer and and and
and solve these problems technology wise
so I guess I'm I'm all over the place um
you when you when you people think about
you know when your role you know in
kahoun you know what is sort of your
Lighthouse you know when when you think
about the chief Med medical officer and
specifically you within within your
mission to provide these tools to be
able to allow pH to to allow it scale to
help more people so where's sort of your
your core here in in this Mission what
do people look to you for um so you know
the healthcare Healthcare System and the
good thing about it is there's so much
to do
um because uh so much can be uh improved
to for for us to give better care for
patients and the market is changing all
the time um and you know we had the the
pandemic and and and and we have and
different technologies that that are
coming out and and are opportunities for
us uh and we have to look at it at them
and and see how they can uh uh we can
use different uh technology and uh
aspects of of the market to really bring
kahun to that vision of incorporated
into the workflow of
physician to to help them make more
informed decisions along the the
journeys of of of managing patients and
I think in the company it's this is um
this is this is how I I I feel that I I
and there is always uh that point of of
vision of how to what common is aimed to
be be and we always have even in this
changing Market we Al always have to
keep on track and bring this to life
because it is so important to bring it
to I I completely completely agree um
what enjoy most about your work um well
I mean it's it has to be the people that
I'm working with because we have a great
team here and and we have you know it's
it's it's such a joy working with these
uh uh fantastic people who are dedicated
to the mission that we are all working
on together and it's fun and we have a
very good environment here uh fruitful
environment for everyone that uh can
bring in their cre creativity and ideas
and we'll have amazing discussions uh
all the time on how to again how to to
solve the problems that come up all the
time and it's it's just working with
these uh with these people this is what
I love and it it definitely sounds like
it and uh and uh it sounds like you're
you're out to do a you know really
positive impact with kahoun and and it
sounds like your role is sort of this
integrator and being the focal point of
the medical scene with the AI scene and
the development and the product and
understanding the complexities of the
patients and the complexities of the
system and uh being at a time in which
you know we're under an AI Revolution
and you know a lot of the technology is
being made accessible and you're you're
specializing in how to bring it how to
bring this layer of professionalism in
the medical scene to the way that that
the people can can converse with it and
that at least that's part of what we
talked about early on in the beginning
but then having you know this the
Professional Knowledge from your the
domain that you're in to be able to
actually leverage that and provide a
higher level of intelligence than the
traditional the traditional systems
right yes wonderful and M I really want
to thank you for coming here this was
really great and and I really appreciate
the time and and it can tell how how big
of a Believer you are in in sort of this
integration of everything that that
you're doing and big believer in in how
technology is coming in the intersection
of this field and so again thank you
very much for the time and for the
inspiration I really enjoyed it thank
you I enjoyed it so much thank you so
much for having than you